[Applaudissements]
ça va aller
c'est extraordinaire d'être centre vous
là maintenant je sais pas si vous vous
arrive en fait d'être perdu dans le
temps et l'espace d'avoir le sentiment
de déjà-vu être partout en fait mon
travail c'est ça je suis constamment en
fait dans une recherche d'un univers qui
n'existe pas ou qui va exister dans une
sorte de souvenirs de venir alors j'ai
commencé en fait par vous dire que il ya
quelques semaines en fait j'ai fini la
lecture d'un livre d'un écrivain qui
s'appelle michel jeury qui en fait un
écrivain de science fiction
le livre s'appelle temps incertain dans
ce livre en fête
l'écrivain a inventé un personnage qui
en fait fait une sorte de science ou des
sciences qu'il a baptisé la chronologie
ce qui en fait ce personnage est un
chercheur en médecine il développe à
base de drogue en fait une sorte de
pertes sur perturbations de perception
par rapport au temps et l'espace est en
fait pourquoi je vous raconte ça parce
qu'on en fait
quand j'ai dit que quand j'ai lu le
livre en fait je me suis vraiment senti
le de ce personnage en fait ils t'ont 6
6 6 mois en fait qu'il incarne
bon je vais commencer par vous montrer
quelques images
un photographe il s'appelle nick iwai ce
qui intéresse en fait dans ses formes
c'est que
le photographe s'intéresse beaucoup à ce
qu on peut l'appeler architecture
d'insectes ou ce que la nature en fait
nous propose comme possibilités
esthétiques énorme el jammal yates en
fait ce qui ce qui est super intéressant
c'est que toute la géométrie l'aspect
géométriques spirituel et architecturale
et déjà inventé par par des insectes par
des animaux par la nature par les cours
l'écosystème en fait je vous laisse
méditer sur les photos
[Musique]
en fait si vous voulez le la dre guyon
métisse biomimétisme qui en fait une
un processus que aujourd'hui en fait la
science et la technologie l'ingénierie
et l'architecturé s'inspire pour en
faire un monde extraordinaire
donc si vous voulez moi j'essaie de
d'aborder la même démarche qu'un insecte
par exemple ou un animal qui se base
principalement sur son institution pour
construire fonds ni son espace à louis
son espace intime faire rêver externe en
2012 j'ai commencé un projet j'étais en
fait inviter dans une résidence
d'artiste à tétouan en plein coeur de la
médina et en fait on se baladant je me
suis dit comment ça peut être comment ça
peut devenir en fait cet espace dans
quelques centaines d'années
comment il va se transformer et ses
excès et j'essaie en fait de d'observer
juste autour de moi tout ce qui se passe
au niveau d'architecturé d'urbanisme en
faisant un voyage de casablanca tétouan
je suis tombé sur un chantier de
construction de ponts ou plus
précisément j'ai vu ce monolithe en fait
en fait une étape de construction qui
ressemble vraiment un monolithe qu'on
retrouve un peu similaire dans les films
de science fiction dans les jeux vidéo
donc à travers sa géométrie des comment
ça peut être par exemple la médina de
tétouan en introduisant en fait des
formes architecturaux à ce brutaliste
même au coeur de la médina ont tous
commencé le projet en fait et je
commençais à faire un travail de l'image
de synthèse en retouchant des images et
introduisant en fait des formes très
brutal istres est très menaçant en même
temps
donc en fait l'emploi quand je viens de
dire je crée des j'essaye de créer en
fait des univers d'une architecture qui
éventuellement ne sert absolument à rien
qui est juste là il part présentent ils
peur menaçante et a en fait à ne faire
peur c'est comme si on construit les
choses pour nous faire peur ce comme une
sorte d'obsession en fait j'ai
longuement fait aujourd'hui on construit
pour pour nous sublimer en fait je vous
laisse en même temps regarder les images
donc à partir de ce moment là en fait
j'ai commencé à créer en 3d en fait en
images de synthèse des blocs de grès
temps et je les introduit en fait dans
des ruelles concert au coeur de la
médina qui a placé dans un aspect très
une sorte de l'ère post apocalyptique où
le silence mère j'en fais tout on est
vraiment dans une sorte de vide où
l'homme n'est plus là en fait l'homme
si conscient en fait elle a tout
construit pour ce disparaître en fait
pour laisser place au fond
comme vous pouvez vous voyez en fait une
sorte de monolith en fait une sorte de
construction qui qui n'adhère absolument
pas aux lois de physique qui sont juste
là il pas présentes hyper forte
je voulais si vous voulez en fait
regarder un petit extrait de de diaw
éthologie en fait le film sur la médina
de tétouan
en fait on ma démarche de travail
je trouve ça super intéressant de vous
le dire en fait c'est que avant avant
justement de passer à faire griffins par
exemple ou des images de synthèse je
fais beaucoup de dessins en fait une
sorte de pré production dans laquelle en
fait j'essaie de construire csg nezzar
en fait
[Musique]
graphiquement avant 2 avant de les
réaliser
quand vous pouvez voir sur les images
donc c'est cdc des dessins en fait où je
me suis vraiment amusée à la question
est ce que c'est la construction de
façon globale tout en la réduisant dans
une sorte de pierre qui était justement
la priorité le premier élément de
construction par l'homme en fait après
je vais parler en fait d'un de mon
deuxième projet que j'ai en fait réalisé
en russie de la finlande en fait en
collaboration avec une artiste suédoise
qui s'appelle anna nelson est en fait le
projet a consisté en fait le livre
s'appelle hallyday heureux qui en fait
une île de construite par le régime de
régimes nazis pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
et c'est une île qui était
un champ de bataille où nous sommes
arrivés en fait elle était tellement
vite il n'y avait absolument rien que
des traces du passage de langues
ce que l'on en fait a laissé derrière
lui je trouve ça hallucinant parce que
enfin sur place j'ai calqué le même
modèle de sept-îles sur deux sur les
villes d'aujourd'hui par exemple sur
nous nos villes et je me suis dit
comment ça peut être par exemple le new
york paris ou abu dhabi après la
disparition de l'homme après la grande
catastrophe
donc si vous voulez en fait j'ai
toujours tendance de de créer des
univers post apocalyptique où lang
justement éclat n'est pas n'est pas là
quand mon pouvoir sur les images
desigual crise sans aucune ressource
sans rien qu'on pouvait le constater je
sais pas si vous vous le sentez au pain
il ya un caractère très menaçant en fait
mais en même temps ce qui est
intéressant c'est que commet un drame
peut se profère muniz et par exemple
peut se transformer en quelque chose
d'hallucinant de beau donc je me suis
amusé amusé à prendre des images et a
essayé de la sublime heures en fait pour
les rendre un peu plus menaçant au fait
si je sais d'action dax entier ce
caractère en fait après après la phase
de prise de photos j'ai commencé en fait
à construire un lycée de construire avec
les moyens de bord
une sorte de d'architecturé de maquettes
comme vous pouvez voir je savais que des
chaises créer des compositions de
six conseillers en fait j'avais vraiment
enfants de moi envie de de créer une
sorte de rencontre improbable entre deux
types d'architecturés qu'on peut voir
sur les images une architecture voyant
conventionnelles ont normale et une
autre qui est juste à côté qui ne sert à
rien en fait
et c'est ça en fait ce qui m'intéresse
c'est vraiment apporté 1 1
un caractère très absurde par rapport à
la construction après de mon retour à
casablanca je me suis amusé en fait à
construire à s'inspirer profondément de
tout refaire tout le patrimoine
militaire pour en faire en fait une
sorte de retranscription en fait de
forme en en métal
je travaille avec des artisans pour le
pot de fin en fait donc je sais quoi si
vous arrivez en fait à créer l onf a
créé le lien entre entre ce caractère d'
architecture que j'ai commencé à faire
en images de synthèse est ce que j'ai pu
faire en fait par la suite avec des
vrais fort avec de vraies images c'est
toujours la recherche de quelque chose
de qui là qu'on ne sait pas qui est ce
qu'il est en train de faire c'est comme
si on a on est tous ses parrains
veilleuse qui qui efface la mémoire et
qu'on est touchant font tous en fait
tous est touché par ce virus
et comment justement va on va on va
revoir ces objets qui nous entourent ces
architectures qui nous entoure c'est
presque la même chose qui m'intéresse
quand vous pouvez voir en fait toujours
la recherche d'une esthétique très
esthétique de vite si vous voulez
donc en finalisant le monolithe en fait
comme le hasard fait les choses en fait
j'étais en train de prendre des photos
il y avait en fait les gens là qui sont
en train de passer et je me suis
vraiment dit si con si on est vraiment
dans une ère post apocalyptique et qu'
il reste peu de quelques-uns en fait
qu'ils sont là des indigènes qui passe
mouvance je sais pas ce vaisseau spatial
où cette forme qui est qui qui
complètement absurde
après j'ai gardé la même façon de
travailler c'est à dire refaire dès lors
de l' architecture mais son matériau en
fait vous changer juste le matériau
garder juste les éléments de
construction comme une sorte de design
de l'architecturé et faire de la lumière
c'est à dire comment je peux arriver
avec avec ces éléments là à donner un
aspect spirituel parler du viêt ou
parler du l'absence de langues parlées
des choses enfin
donc c'est après comment aussi en fait
je me pose souvent en fait la question
de s que l' architecture est un art ou
pas parce qu'en fait avant de faire les
beaux-arts
mon rêve c'était de faire de l'
architecture mais vu que m'ont dit que
l'on était en arc classique
j'ai postulé pour l'école est terrorisé
et pour allart par la suite en fait six
ans après je me suis trouvé en train de
faire des interventions dans des écoles
d'architecturé et à dire aux étudiants
que voilà si je suis avec vous
maintenant ce que parce que je soumets
en fait c'est parce que ce n'était pas
le bon profil pour faire de
l'architecturé
mais paradoxalement je consomme ni
toujours à faire la même obsession de
façon complètement folle affaire de
l'architecturé mais vraiment de ma façon
et après voilà ça c'est moi qui ne cesse
de jouer et de faire rêver et de rêver
sans merci